welcome well I've been spending the last
few years making videos and writing
software and I thought it was about time
that actually showed people how to use
everything and how to access everything
in where they could find things so this
is a screenshot of the site that you are
probably looking at and what you might
find intriguing is the fact that in the
screenshot i have a snapshot of the
video that i am currently recording so
you can maybe think about how that
happened but anyway this is the Khan
Academy youtube channel and I recently
became a partner off of one of your
suggestions but I get these these
questions all the time from people who
have trouble finding something or they
ask me about a subject that that's
actually already covered or they find
part 2 of a video but it's like where's
part 3 or worse part 1 and I just wanted
to show you how to navigate it and i
also want to show you how you can access
the software that that i've written and
it's all free so you know you can bear
with me it just keep in mind that it was
written by one guy in his spare time
anyway first the videos so the best way
to navigate the videos is on the
playlist there's two places to find the
playlist link either right there that's
the easiest one there's another one down
there where they shall playlist
unfortunately youTube allows you to
display three playlist so i think most
people don't see all of the place we
have a bunch of them so but if you click
here see all playlists or up here you
click on the playlist you will see all
of the playlists and these are these are
categorized in alphabetical order and in
each playlist have all of the videos on
that subject matter so if you click on
algebra you see all of our algebra
videos and this is algebra two
essentially so it's everything that's
algebra that's why our pre calculus
playlist is fairly short because
everything that could be algebra is in
the algebra playlist and everything this
calculus is in calculus playlist so
precalculus we just do a little bit on
limits and and graphs and sequences and
series and things like that but you can
see we have a ton of playlists far more
than the three that you see on the main
page even have a little bit on Finance
if you are home schooling your child and
they're young they can start on the
arithmetic playlist after arithmetic the
next one to do is pre-algebra after
pre-algebra you can do either algebra
the algebra playlist
and you could probably simultaneously
watch the geometry playlist where is
that G for geometry the geometry
playlist after those you can do the
trigonometry playlist and the the pre
calculus playlist and of course we have
calculus and we have probability
probability the prerequisite for that
playlist I would say is probably just
pre-algebra maybe you might want to
watch the algebra playlist before you
watch that finance this is for everyone
I've made this for family and friends
just so they can have maybe a more
structured way of understanding how how
things are priced etc etc but in general
and all of these playlists you can
actually I think you can actually just
subscribe to the playlist so if you
really just care about algebra you don't
get notified whenever I upload a finance
video but I want to let everyone know
that i take requests if you all I ask is
that you first go to the playlist and
make sure that I haven't already covered
that or a similar topic but i take
requests send me a note say hey Sal I
love your playlist but I would love it
even more if you had if you did this
problem or if you covered this topic and
I'm more than happy to do it so send me
some problems and one playlist I want to
focus on because it's well it's
something that can get kind of messy
because there's so many problems we've
actually done all of the s80 problems in
the main s80 study guide that people buy
and if you go to playlist it just has
all of the problems in order and there's
there's 400 problems so if someone
misses you know someone doesn't know how
to do problem three on on page 4 71 it's
hard to navigate it here so I wanted to
show you the alternate way to navigate
it you just go to the Khan Academy
website you just click on the banner at
the top of the channel and it'll take
you there but it's just khanacademy org
you can see it up there khanacademy org
and if you're just doing s80 prep click
here or you can click up here on s80
prep and it also has the other videos
but the playlist on YouTube are actually
updated more frequently and have a lot
more contact I think we have 400 videos
on YouTube really have 200 videos here
so for everything else you should
actually use the YouTube content if you
want the latest and the most videos but
for the s80 prep you click on
CTR you can click here this is the book
that you should get it's the official
s80 study guide it has eight practice
tests and we've done all of the math
problems in those practice tests and
then when you click on our our link it
has all of the problems categorized by
the test to categorized by the section
categorized by the section and by the
problem so what was it problem number
three on page 4 71 if you don't how to
do that you just click there and you
actually get that each video has three
or four problems but it becomes a lot
easier to navigate and we explain
exactly how to do it and once again what
I recommend is that you or your student
whoever is preparing for the s80 does
the problems ahead of time and then you
buys the book does the problems ahead of
time takes the practice test and then
uses this as a resource to make sure
that they understand things and to
really realize that all of the problems
are are doable but anyway hopefully that
gives you a sense of all the videos we
have once again I'm not only just video
suggestions I'm open to playlist
suggestions if there's topics that you
would especially like to have access to
and then the other thing that I've
mentioned and other people wanted access
to is the actual site the the software
application that we've written and until
today we've been using it a bunch of
schools and I've kind of been giving
access to it on a one-off basis but I've
decided that I think it's good enough
now for for general use so you can
actually register for an account just by
clicking on register and just put your
email address and your desired password
it doesn't have to be too secure this
isn't a bank account I don't think
anyone really cares about being logging
in as you and doing your math problems
for you but once you register you login
you just go to the login page and
actually I'm going to login as as my
cousin his name is Ali I can't tell you
what his password is and just you know
right after your no matter are in
calculus or if you are a a kindergartner
the first problem that you will see and
when you login you'll under practice
you'll see basic addition here and
that's all you will see and that's the
only thing that you can click on and
you'll have nothing under review and
basic addition is essentially problems
like 1 plus 1 or 3 plus 5 and as you
progress forward as you get streaks of
problems right the system will actually
will actually assign
more and more advanced to problems to
you so what after you get five and I
think ten in a row on basic edition
it'll become a review problem and you'll
get points for it actually have your
energy points up here and and you just
keep progressing and let me see if my
cousin is C so this is level for
addition just so you know what a module
looks like so this is after you've
progressed a little bit and so if a
student doesn't want to do this actually
can click this the hints and it tells
you every step and so all of them are
visual in different ways but if you go
to exercises start you admit if you if
you work on it it'll probably take you
about if you're saying your middle smear
in middle school or 9th or 10th grade
it'll probably take you about two hours
I'd say to get to your level and and the
reason why I we do that is because we
found that a lot of people even though
their ninth or tenth grade they might
just kind of have some mistakes or some
misunderstandings on how to do
subtraction or fractions and it's really
good you just put that to our investment
in and then you're sure and the system
sure that you don't have any pesky gaps
in your knowledge if anyway looks like
it's a few of the other modules they're
all different this is multiplying
expressions that's where my cousin is
right now and he's actually he's
actually a sixth grader so I'm very
proud of him that you know he's already
well anyway I don't know I don't want to
I don't want to boast but anyway so this
is multiplying expressions and so this
is your typical you know you either view
it as the distributive property or foil
depending how you learned it you could
watch the video if you don't know how to
do it and it has the video on this exact
concept the YouTube video that's pumped
out of our YouTube channel but let's say
after watching the video you think you
know how to do it you try it out you
click on an answer and you say oh no I
got it wrong and you want to know you
want to know why you got it wrong or the
exact steps when you just click on hint
and it gives you the exact steps of how
to solve that problem and just so you
know there are infinite problems here
each these there isn't just some
database with ten problems and then as
soon as you do those ten problems its
run out these are all dynamically
generated by the computer dynamically
generated just means it's the computer
thinks of the problem right when you you
need it so it thinks of some random
numbers and generates it and it'll
generate the the the hints to so if it
takes you a million problems too
stand a concept it will give you a
million problems you will never ever run
out of examples and just some of these
so stuff this is comfort level this is
your own self-assessment if you're doing
this on a one-off basis you can fill out
this if you want but this is really for
schools so that when do aggregate
reporting we can get data on on just how
confident the kids feel and teachers can
see that this is your streak if you got
one right or to write it so it shows up
here go back to exercises I could show
you or just so you how is it what it
looks like some of them are are more
visual this is functions and if you
click on hinted you evaluate the
function there's there's a ton there's
there's word problems right here and if
you click on video it gives you an
example of how to do word problems like
that and then if you want data on your
on your own you know how you're doing
there's a bit of a report card here
under stats under stats it's taking a
little time to load maybe this is my
cousin's report card you see like level
2 angles he's gotten 10 out of 10 but
he's kind of lukewarm he feels
reasonably comfortable at it he's gotten
forty-one percent correct he's gotten
forty percent of the last ten so I don't
know he got he got ten in a row so maybe
he maybe he hasn't done it for a long
time but whatever and then the pond
thing I want to go over and I want to be
careful when I go over this because last
time I recorded a video on this because
it's kind of intensive graphically I
think my this the software that I'm
using to record my voice into the screen
capture really slow down slow down and I
started to sound like I was melting and
running out of batteries so I'm just
going to show it to you really fast and
then jump out of it because I don't want
to slow down again but essentially shows
shows you the big picture of if you're
on am a time to load up so I warned you
about that graphically all the modules
that are in the system basic edition you
see on the left hand side that's where
you start off and as you get streaks
right there it'll progress you forward
forward the yellow modules are things
that that you have become proficient in
and the deep orange you'll see later
are the modules that are the month that
you you are currently working on and so
we have that knowledge map and I got out
of it just because I didn't want things
to slow down and I didn't want to start
sounding like like a transformer but
hopefully you'll nos the knowledge map
is there just so you know where it's
going and what what have you learned
what if what are you currently learning
and why are you learning it so you can
know what concepts that will eventually
get you to and in general I think you'll
find this software pretty useful if you
are doing anything up to about I don't
know algebra to trigonometry even if
you're in college you'll probably find
this a really really good math review
it'll get you to about the precalculus
level and our goal is eventually to
catch up with the videos and cover
things like trigonometry and all of
calculus and differential equations in
linear algebra and just so you know big
picture our goal is to cover all of
knowledge eventually it's taking us
about two or three years to get this far
maybe we'll bring on some more people
some more volunteers maybe some people
record things in other languages but our
goal my goal is to keep doing this until
until the day I die and hopefully that's
a long time from now so that I can I can
do many many many videos anyway enjoy
and send me a note if you find it useful
or if you have any questions and I look
forward to seeing you in future videos